- [Narrator] There's been a domino effect
in the collapse of the crypto industry.
(dominoes falling)
The fall of the stable
coin Terra sparked a wave
of losses leading to bankruptcy filings
for five major crypto
companies, paused withdrawals
and declining value for
cryptocurrencies but-
- The contagion effects
to the wider economy have been limited
so there's like massive carnage over here
but not much impact over here.
- [Narrator] Usually when
an industry collapses,
(dominoes falling)
it has the potential to
ripple far out to other parts
of the economy and can even
spark a financial crisis.
But so far, for crypto the fallout
has been pretty contained.
Here's why the crypto industries collapse
has happened in a closed loop.
(dominoes falling)
The finances of many crypto
companies are intertwined.
- It's a very incestuous kind of scene
where you have the same
companies lending to each other,
borrowing from each other, and
then trading with each other.
- [Narrator] Just looking
at a slice of the industry,
you can see how closely related
those five bankrupt companies were.
Three Arrows, a crypto focused
hedge fund, had invested
in crypto assets and companies
and took loans out from other companies.
One of these investments was
Terra's sister token Luna.
When these assets fell,
so did Three Arrows' balance sheet.
As a result, the company
failed to repay debts
and was ordered to liquidate in June.
In the wake of that bankruptcy,
crypto lenders, BlockFi, Voyager
and Celsius were taking losses
on declining digital currency prices
and on loans they had
given to Three Arrows.
Then Crypto Exchange FTX extended a line
of credit to BlockFi
and its sister company
Alameda extended a line to Voyager.
Voyager filed for bankruptcy in July.
A few days later, Celsius did too
and when FTX filed for
bankruptcy in November
due to a mismanagement of
funds, BlockFi followed.
- It's like these
companies are all wearing
these different hats with each other
so you can see how these
companies are so interconnected
and so intermingled that it sets the stage
for contagion to have a
really devastating effect.
- [Narrator] The Financial
Stability Oversight Council
said in a report in October
that this interconnectedness is part
of why the industry
can crumble so quickly.
One of the reasons those
companies are so tightly linked,
traditional finance
institutions have stayed
pretty separated from crypto.
For example, if you look at the list
of some of Celsius' biggest creditors
in their bankruptcy filing,
there aren't any banks listed.
- In other industries, for example,
banks will provide credit lines
or arrange corporate bonds
or do other sorts of financings.
In crypto it's been much more limited.
There just hasn't been
the same embrace that
other industries have seen.
- [Narrator] A small handful of banks
like these have courted crypto companies,
but big players in the financial market
have been more hesitant.
- Okay, I'm a major skeptic
on crypto tokens, which you
call currency like Bitcoin.
- [Narrator] Regulation for
banks which is helped set
by the Office of the
Comptroller of the Currency
requires them to have a
number of safety measures
in place before engaging
with digital assets.
- The resilience of the
traditional banking system
to the recent events in
crypto is not an accident.
Rather, it is due, at least in part
to federal bank regulators continued
and intentional emphasis on safety
and soundness and consumer protection.
- [Narrator] Crypto makes up just 0.01%
of exposure for banks.
- Since the traditional
Wall Street banks have not
really participated in
the space, it's been left
to the crypto companies themselves to act
as like defacto banks within the space.
You see how these companies
have become so interconnected
and intermingled that the failure of one
can bring down the rest.
- [Narrator] But that
isolation has helped prevent
the crypto crisis from spilling
into the larger economy.
Think about the housing crash in 2007
that eventually led to
the Great Recession.
When housing prices declined,
it sparked a crisis in subprime loans.
As some banks had a stake
in these type of mortgages,
that crisis leaked into the
traditional financial system.
- It began to snowball and
cause a system-wide meltdown
and major financial institutions
like Lehman Brothers
failed because of their
exposure to the housing market.
- [Narrator] Other industries like housing
also have value in the economy.
There's dollars behind it,
but crypto's value is
still mostly speculative.
- This is what happens when you have a lot
of money pouring into
an unregulated industry
that has little discernible clear value
aside from the speculation itself.
- [Narrator] While the crash
has been mostly contained
in this case, it's left a lot of questions
about how financial
institutions might interact
with the industry in the future.